[Music]
you're listening to inside of you with
michael rosenbaum ryan is here with me
ryan good uh morning afternoon evening
whenever you're listening yes i hope
you're uh i hope you're enjoying the
podcast each week and uh hope you're
enjoying your week and i really just
want to say i appreciate you uh tuning
in whether you watch on youtube or
whether you listen on stitcher or apple
or whatever spotify spread the word
write a review it really helps the show
we always say that but you know maybe
new listeners are listening because
they're listening to stephen amell and
we'll get right into the interview
by the way um
but uh hey i'll be in atlanta at dragon
con
this coming weekend and then the
following weekend in lexington kentucky
at a con and then in west virginia at
the end of the month so just look on uh
twitter or all that stuff
but uh come see me it'll be fun i'm
doing a smallville nights with tom
welling in in lexington kentucky
that's a lot of fun and uh doing one by
myself in west virginia on like the 24th
or something that weekend
uh also if you want to buy any merch the
inside of you online store 10 off all
merch the
the code is that what you'd say yeah
that's the thing you say is ryan is 10
for 10 off ryan is 10. ryan is 10. oh
ryan
r-y-a-n-i-s-10 like you're years old
yeah maybe and then my band sunspin if
you go to sunspin.com
uh you want any merch
10 off all merch rob is 10. r-o-b-i-s-10
rob is 10. what are these socials ryan
uh they are at inside of you pod on
twitter inside of you podcast on
facebook and instagram please follow us
we love that
and what was the other thing oh patreon
if you want to join the lovely patreon
family uh to support the podcast a
little bit more i love that i'll message
you right away or as soon as i can just
go to patreon.com
inside of you p-a-t-r-e-o-n
dot com slash inside of you uh we got a
great podcast today stephen amell he's
been on the podcast a few times before
but every time he comes he gives a
surprise he talks about something else
something he brings it he brings it i
love having this guy in the show he
doesn't live far from me
and he's always a sport
and i just want to say thanks steven if
you're listening
which i i hope you do
uh it's a really fun interview i think
you guys are going to really enjoy this
and his new show heals on stars make
sure you watch that uh it's a good time
that is a good time amateur wrestling at
its best for sure let's get into stephen
amell
it's my point of view
you're listening to inside of you with
michael rosenbaum
[Music]
inside of you with michael rosenbaum was
not recorded in front of a live studio
audience
dude you've been on a few times i'm
pumped to have you back thank you i mean
you've really run the game in a sense
that you you know you've had you had a
we had a great episode then you had a
anxiety attack i did which then you it
was still a great episode and then you
came back and you said you had covid i
mean you've been a guest that has like
all these surprises
every
yeah and there's two things that i want
to do before we can get into whatever
you have to say i don't have anything
are you ready yeah
i want to do this for a long time
because i listen to the show all right
it's my point of view
you're listening to inside of you
with michael rosenbaum
yes you know i thought it that is
beautiful thank you ryan give it up for
the [ __ ] mel and mel doing that you
know no one's ever done that and by the
way
do you think i should keep that
never change it never change it for
anybody ever ever ever ever that's kind
of my thing
it was just it's the thing now it's like
the bmw that i saw in the carport as i
was walking in here it's it's there it's
the one that has the dust that's clearly
been it wasn't my bmw no it wasn't but
it was like a three series from like
2001 and it's clearly been in that
parking spot since 2000 i mean just in
front of my house yeah yeah people don't
move they just like park their cars and
then i end up getting them towed because
i'm tired of looking at that car
i have done that before i have a second
thing yeah go ahead and go please okay
i'm so excited for this okay i got asked
to get off a plane
leaving austin texas i i heard about
that and i was like i know you texted me
yes texted me but like so i love that
you just see you're unlike any other
guest i have a guest like i just
interviewed and they're like i don't
want to talk about that and you talk
about everything you're an open book and
that's why i think it's it's healthy and
people like you uh thank you i wanted to
have just a slight runway here to be
able to
talk about this because
what happened was and it's very very
simple all right i had
too many drinks and i had too many
drinks in a public place right
and i got on a plane
and
the reason that i want to talk about it
is and we'll get to it eventually this
will all make sense
is
i was pissed off about something else
that had nothing to do with cass my wife
right and i picked a fight just i picked
a fight because i wanted to be
loud
and upset
and it was a fight
as in like it was not an argument in
order to have an argument
two people people have to be
engaged my wife said one thing the
entire time which was if you don't lower
your voice
they're going to ask you to get off the
plane that's the only thing that she
said the entire time what are you doing
the whole time i was i can't even you
know honestly i can't even remember what
i was upset about which was indicative
of two things a
handle your liquor i had too many drinks
right and
and b it clearly wasn't important i was
just upset
and wanted to be
upset and sure enough after she said
this
a guy came by and said sir you have to
keep your voice down please
just a random guy or a flight attendant
uh it wasn't a flight attendant it was
the guy that the flight attendant had
clearly called so obviously cass was 100
right here right i was being loud i was
probably dropping a few f-bombs
i've got the noise canceled this is
non-excuse i'm not here to make i'm not
here to make excuses
yeah and i don't even want to i don't
want to smile while i'm telling this
story because it i'm actually frankly
like deeply ashamed of it
um
but
i got asked i was quiet for 10 minutes
the guy came back clearly i had made
somebody uncomfortable and someone had
said something
and they just make the decision you got
to get off the plane so i got off the
plane i booked on the next flight
i went from did you sober up for the
next flight
yeah i sure did
why because i was sitting in row 17 in
the middle seat as a as opposed to i i
mean i want to get home right
but uh
but then i found out that it was going
to come out on tmz and
and when i found that out and the reason
i want to bring it up is because i
talked about it and in my one thing that
i said about it on the internet i
referred to it as an argument between my
wife and i
and it wasn't it was not an argument it
was just you being loud it was me this
is a hundred percent my fault like
i i feel like i went
the better part of ten years without you
know being an [ __ ] in public
i was an [ __ ] in public well she how
pissed was cass super pissed and she
should be pissed and she was frankly uh
even more pissed when i
said argument as opposed to
pick a fight
and i sent that tweet at like four
o'clock in the morning because i woke up
to a text from my buddy in toronto that
just said are you okay and i went oh my
god it's out it's out
and they used this shitty old photo from
like seven years ago and the whole the
whole thing sucks it's it's it's it's
it's it's it's really
it's really really shameful and it makes
you kind of look look in the mirror and
and i just realized a couple of things
don't
uh
you know if people are gonna recognize
you uh you know don't necessarily drink
in a public place but more importantly
don't drink in a public place if you
can't handle your [ __ ] but i've never
known you to be someone who can't handle
their alcohol or gets a little uh out
there with it well on occasion
that is what happens but i mean don't do
it on a plane you [ __ ] loser
and and that was it and you texted me on
the on the b side of it so i mean that's
it that's the whole story but
you know the the
the long tail the b side of it is
the [ __ ] phone calls that you have to
make apologizing because
the story hits and you know
i've got to call my mom and i've got a
call what happened what were you doing
are you okay are you okay buddy it's
like yes i'm okay let me ask you this
did you resist them taking off the plane
no and that's the scariest part for me
the scariest part is that i was
inebriated
i was upset
and it would have been very easy when
the gentleman came up and said
you collect your things let's talk at
the top of the entrance way and i said
to
him please do not make me get off this
plane
i i was focusing i was staring out the
window i wasn't going to say a word for
the next two and a half hours
and he said we'll collect your things
we'll talk about at the top of the
entrance way and i went
okay
but you were tempted to be a little bit
well what if i if i if i just casually
flippantly
not being in
sound mind and body
if i offer like a quick passive [ __ ] off
and all of a sudden i'm in i'm in
bracelets yeah
i i might i mean maybe i destroyed my
entire life my entire career so i think
ultimately
very ashamed of it trying to make amends
for it specifically with with my wife
but she's forgiven you at this point
this has been a while i mean i mean it's
a work it's a work in progress it was
it's not the best right i mean you can
you can work through things but that
doesn't mean they didn't happen
right what kind of conversations do you
have at home do you have conversations
like cass saying things like i don't
like seeing you like that i don't want
to be around that well i mean not
not since not since that point right
but i don't know i just
you know this is a weird experience that
we all live in where
people just sort of give you whatever
you want
and
and occasionally that leads to just not
setting appropriate boundaries in your
own in your own life
so we're having conversations about that
about just basic stuff and you know it's
it's a good thing but i'm it's a good
thing that we have those conversations
i'm just i'm just happy that i didn't
give the tertiary passive
[ __ ] off
because then i'm in a
then i'm in jail in austin
yeah and then it's bigger than it was
well then then like
yeah it was bigger than it was to begin
with right it's just like can i just
[ __ ] up in peace please and like by
myself because i see lots of people
drunk on planes oh my god but that guy's
so [ __ ] loud
and they're being belligerent you're
like oh my god this guy's gonna be a
problem on the on the plane somebody
take this guy off and it makes you
uncomfortable
i've seen that with a lot i mean a lot
of people some people don't like to fly
they like to drink their way through
sure you know people like you know i
take maybe uh
a little bit of a xanax or i used to i
don't think with that to kind of chill
out it's been a while
but like especially in those long
flights
i get anxiety man i've had anxiety
attacks on planes where i'm like
i think i need to tell them to emergency
land i can't [ __ ] do this and i have
to talk myself out of it i got to listen
to some kind of music and the guy next
to me is like mike he's got to be aware
of him so
which episode of your podcast you put on
to relax yourself
you know what's funny
i don't
i don't know none of them do you fall
asleep in the sound of your own voice
for sure listen to my episodes
i don't listen to my episodes i swear to
god one occasion i've listened
i'd say out of the 150 that i've done i
might have listened to half an episode
um i trust ryan in his editing i trust
bryce producer and i just i i did the
interview i had a nice moment with
someone i don't feel like you know what
you said listen to what well you know
what you said as in like you i know what
i see you know what you said yeah i know
what i said okay well hey if i meandered
at all through this i'm looking at the
looking at ryan the producer right now
if i meandered it all through this
explanation just just remember the key
points are totally my fault [ __ ] up
not a fight
okay it's gonna be not an argument
i can cut around the words to make it
seem like it thank you very much
on stars because i just watched it and i
i really freaking loved it but first you
know it's funny my first question was
because i don't think we ever talked
about it was you know it's funny
i wanted to talk to but you went to
school for all school for boys which
started making me think didn't you learn
anything after you just told me a story
this is all school for boys what was it
like going to a school for boys was it
the disciplinary thing with you no it
wasn't my dad went there school called
saint andrews college
uh it was in aurora ontario just north
of toronto and i i we lived in toronto
but that's about an hour away so i
boarded i loved it i loved it and
couldn't stop meeting girls the second
the second that i went there
what well how's that possible it's not i
don't know his school i was very
handsome as a teenager you found a way
didn't you but they weren't
disciplinarians they weren't like very
strict at this school no that school's
the reason that i'm an actor
what do you mean
uh william schooler was the
drama teacher when i was there i believe
that he is still the
the head of drama at st andrews and
uh
he would
literally go down
to
the field where the first football team
the varsity football team practiced
and he would
grab guys that played football or played
soccer or played rugby
or
played hockey
and he would tell them that they needed
to be involved in the fall play or the
spring play or the drama festival that
we put on the spring called focus
and he would get i mean what's what's
the what's the stereotypical delineation
for high schools you have jocks
you what geeks geeks uh
where did theater people fall uh theater
goers beer goers or yeah what would you
call theater go thespians sure festival
sure yes so the cool thing about st
andrews is that they didn't
allow
the student body to just
specialize
you want to play hockey great
you got to go
be a jet in west side story are you
serious i'm dead serious because all i
did was play sports i didn't think about
acting for a second that's gonna be
terrifying for an athlete or someone who
doesn't have any desire to do theater i
i think it's i think it's terrifying and
i think it promotes a huge amount of
growth
it really does i mean there are i mean i
got a buddy nick abraham a buddy kevin
richards both prodigious athletes kevin
played uh played soccer for notre dame
and i think was probably pretty close to
playing nationally for for bermuda
and um oh my god i'm gonna forget his
name for a minute who's the villain on a
west side story rico possibly tony no no
i played tony oh you you played play
tony oh oh
no i said did you sing of course i did
you're a singer yeah
and all of that beautiful sounds
[Music]
yeah yeah wow dude
but that's all because of st andrews
in the boarding life
our school day was not
nine o'clock in the morning to three
o'clock in the afternoon it was seven
o'clock in the morning from
you know waking up your housemates for
breakfast to class to practice or game
uh for the sports team that you're
playing for to
whatever extracurricular thing you would
do i would have days that would start at
seven o'clock in the morning wouldn't
until 10 o'clock at night
what what was your first play
inherit the wind
it's based off the it's it's a book
based off the scope's monkey trial
where they were trying to teach
evolution in a southern classroom right
and i did it to go to a drama festival
in ottawa which is the about five hours
away from toronto just just to meet
girls
and william schooler came up to me the
drama the head of drama and said you
have great focus i would like you to
come and play malcolm in macbeth this
fall
went awesome great that was it
inside of you is brought to you by geico
michael do you owner rent your home uh i
own my home ryan uh well that's good yes
is it hard work it's it's it's always
hard to pay your mortgage or pay your
rent i think we all go through that and
it's also pain in the ass because you
have to pay
um you know it's it's it's a lot to
you know you got a lot of bills to pay
and you could just pay everything at
once oh that'd be nice wouldn't that be
you know who does that
no telling his company
geico
geico if you don't know geico i don't
know what to tell you
because geico makes it easy to bundle
your homeowner's insurance your renter's
insurance along with your auto policy
you go to a grocery store you don't want
to go to a grocery store you have
someone deliver your stuff for you
you know but with geico
same sort of thing bundling policy you
pay it all at once
that's what they do it's geico easy
folks it's so easy i don't know why
you're not doing it that's what i do
just go to geico.com
get a quote and see how much you could
save it's geico easy
go to geico.com today that's geico.com
even a rosenbaum
can do it inside of you is brought to
you by chirp
i don't know what i would do
without my chirp wheel i've got these
three wheels right here which i'll show
you in a second they're so amazing i've
had many back surgeries and have neck
problems and i roll on these things
daily and it helps my spine so much it
helps me relax it releases tension you
have to try this i've never felt i've
seen these wheels before but not like
this these have these divots which makes
it comfortable to roll for your spine
they're not just one hard
you know kind of level
uh wheel where where it's it's a divot
so your spine kind of fits in there
comfortably snug uh chirp wheel is
amazing it's a brand dedicated to
helping the world feel good so they can
do more of the stuff they love in other
words chirp is all about feel good do
more to do this chirp creates simple
innovative and effective pain relief and
prevention solutions chirps started with
a revolutionary wheel for back pain but
they're just getting started back pain
prevents millions of people from feeling
their best when they don't feel their
best they're limited at what they can do
and chirp can help fix that with chirps
patent pending spinal canal and three
different pressure options to choose
from chirp will help your back feel
better so you can be back to doing what
you love
in no time
key features that make this product
stand out there are three different
pressure sizes gentle
medium
and
deep
and a spinal canal to comfort your spine
as our wheels give your back a unique
4-way stretch each wheel can hold up to
500 pounds they can be nestled together
for easy travel to take wherever you go
and all you do guys if you're if you're
suffering with back pain and dealing
with a bunch of issues
you got to try this out it's so
convenient it's the best wheel i've ever
experienced the chirp wheel all you do
is this you visit go chirp.com and enter
the promo code inside to get 10 off site
wide visit go chirp c-h-i-r-p
dot com and enter the promo code inside
to get 10 off site-wide
so but wait a minute the first play you
did were you terrified
uh
no i get i get i get real nervous before
things
but i don't get nervous when i'm
actually on stage what about you do you
well first of all do you do that still
even to this day like when you're
shooting heels you're shooting arrow
you're shooting whatever a movie do you
get nervous gearing up for the roll all
the prep and then once you get on set it
becomes easier
yes
i i get nervous at the beginning of
anything at the beginning of a season at
the beginning of season eight
of arrow right before that first nervous
season
i'm i've i've [ __ ] four times that day
i'm that nervous and does anyone know
that besides you
no
you just keep it to yourself you keep
that confidence you you make it it's a
mirage
well no i no i no i don't i don't keep
the confidence i actually sort of let it
i let it all
i let it all go away so i guess
not everyone knows it
but i will go to the director or our
producing director if i if i knew that
person better
and i'll just say
i
is this okay is this usable am i [ __ ]
up because i
because i
i
i need to hear that
i need to hear that that that take was
good enough you need a little validation
yes i do
i i think most actors do i think a lot
of actors would be better off if they
just
[ __ ] admitted that they need it
and went and got it
go get it do
feel better about the next take
so if i go to james bamford or if i go
to pete siegel on heels or if i go to
mike o'malley
uh our show runner on heels
or glenn winter or gord or whoever the
director is
i'm conflating shows here
and i'm using first names like everyone
knows who i'm talking about i knew glenn
winner from ariel i know i knew pete
segal
well you knew from what you knew glenn
from small some small of course but
it's like hey was that good
yeah it's good but like
last season episode 17 good
or like
we're just moving on to the next shot
good
no steven it was good okay
is that all i need yeah i was literally
just checking and then do you want to
watch the dailies to make sure it was
not no not at all no no in the same way
that you don't listen to your interviews
no i don't need to watch the dailies you
have to watch you trust i do
well i mean if if if they're lying to me
they're [ __ ] everyone they're [ __ ]
that's absolutely true it's it's crazy
uh you asked me
do i get nervous sure i get nervous from
the time like you know director came
over uh this week
and uh offered me this role in this this
little horror movie that i want to do
okay and uh you know i could already
sense the nerves and then you know if i
do it i'll get nervous and then once i
learn the lines and i feel the part and
all of a sudden those nerves will start
to go away more and more and more and
once i'm on set and i'm working stuff
out they'll just start to dissipate you
know what i mean that's kind of how it
works but there's been times
where i'm in my head in the middle of a
scene i'm nervous and no one knows it
but i'm like
i'm freaking out a little have you ever
done that like in the middle of a scene
you're kind of nerf for some reason your
nerves are getting to you
not really
because
i
i don't know i i ex
oh my god i'm gonna use the wrong
analogy
because i've because i've expressed
those nerves
you know like how ben stiller
jerks off before he goes out with mary
okay i do remember that to calm the
nerves yeah or like or or or johnny
drama
in in entourage when he does that as
well right but he said he didn't take
this [ __ ] mic pack off and they hear
it
um
i've i've i've done that you jerk off
i have i have mentally jerked off by
going up to these people and and asking
if things are okay
and so that that that allows me to feel
free during the scene be it
if i ever feel nerves coming up
i'll just go to people that i trust and
and get affirmation besides affirmation
what gets rid of those nerves what keeps
your
keeps you solid keeps you focused keeps
you feeling good about yourself it's
super simple
did i do the work
am i prepared
and that includes probably training
sure yeah you know when you're ready for
stuff right right like you know 150
episodes of this show i'm sure that
there's been interviews that you're you
know
wholly prepared for and ones that kind
of come together last minute or the or
that frankly you just kind of like wing
it like they're i mean i i'm not i'm not
saying i'm not saying that you're not
um
you're not being
those may be some of your best episodes
but
i mean there's a degree
of preparedness and if if i know that
i've done the work then let the chips
fall where they may
i like that
do you
do you get tired now that you're on
another series
of talking about arrow does it is it or
is it too soon or do you just like go
well they just want to talk about arrow
they just want to talk about this or do
you feel like there's kind of uh
a transition now
that you you or you or do you accept it
and you're sort of like this is part of
me this is a big show i loved it it's
great people are gonna always ask me
about this and that's something you've
kind of come into uh just accept you
remember when the rangers lost the
stanley cup final in 2014 yes i do every
moment of it you remember who scored the
goal
when they lost five in games
no it was alec martinez [ __ ] really yeah
he uh to fully came up the right wing
fired a shot lundqvist kicked out the
rebound just [ __ ] yawning cage i
remember seeing it
from the seat that i was in at the
staples center and i blacked out and i
was hugging people 14 rolls up
when i came to
do you think that alec martinez ever
gets tired about talking about that
[ __ ] goal that he scored well that's
isn't that different i i mean for cause
no one really knows alex martinez
exactly
alec alec martinez except for the goal
that he scored in that moment i'll tell
you something right there's a lot of
play i i hear what you're saying okay
but what i'm saying is i mean i there
are a lot of kings fans right now he
plays for a different team now still in
the league right i mean
every time that he gets asked
even if it's
far less than i could ask about arrow he
gets to relive the fact that he scored
an overtime goal at home to win the
stanley cup
and
i'm ready to move on from arrow
but
the only time that anyone ever brings it
up
is to talk about what a [ __ ] raging
success it was right so
and look i'm trying to do this because
you know when we first i guess when we
did our
it would have been our first podcast or
our second podcast
when i had the when i had the panic
attack it's because i was trying to get
away from something without properly
thinking about how important and
impactful and
and just immense
a role it played in my entire life right
i i hear you i would i would say the
analogy wasn't exactly spot on on that
one okay i think the analogy should have
been well but i like martinez decided to
play baseball and he doesn't want to
talk about hockey anymore
that's not a good analogy either as well
no it's been a bit of a but again he's
you know 20 years from now he's going to
be trying to enjoy dinner
down at redondo beach right okay i'm
just assuming that's where like hermosa
or whatever that's where all the all the
all the boys on the kings live manhattan
beach sure whatever live on the beach
and uh you know he's gonna get
interrupted at dinner but he's gonna
have to recall that moment where he
[ __ ] won the stanley cup in overtime
i mean that's also the biggest moment of
his life if like 25 years from now
uh you know hypothetically because
you'll do a lot more but the only thing
you've done was arrow and heels which
are two great shows uh you know you'd
probably
i'm probably what calling you up being
like ah heels came out 20 years today
uh uh let's you wanna you wanna you
wanna beat me
that's a memory that you the world will
remember at least the whole city of los
angeles and i'll forget i forgot it i
didn't even remember it
because i'm not a big and you got this
whole analogy from the uh no you know
the analogies are great we're learning
about analogies as we go on all right
look i want to get into heels because
okay uh you sent me the screener and i
watched it and now i realize how hard
you [ __ ] worked on that
and i know what a perfectionist you are
and i know that you love wrestling so
much you've wrestled with major
wrestlers from the wwe
you've been following it your whole life
i can't imagine that it's that easy for
you to let things go when you're
wrestling on set in scenes and you're
doing something and you're like
is does that look real let me see that
like were you were you so involved in a
lot of those um sequences those fight
sequences i was incredibly involved
i wanted to bring on
people i mean we had luke hawks who's an
independent professional wrestler
he was says tennessee like uh
like on arrow we had an ultra archery
consultant he's like the the wrestling
consultant
but all the backstage stuff the way that
wrestlers would talk to each other the
fact that they
communicate with the referees
um and that the referee is communicating
with someone backstage etc etc like all
of that stuff that's [ __ ] that nobody
knows
because no one from the wrestling world
wants to talk about it because it's cafe
right which is the title of the first
episode which is the parts with the
parts of the wrestling world that you
just don't talk to the public about
right it's like a magician doesn't
give away his tricks
and i've been so fortunate to be
backstage at
at a giant wwe pay-per-view at monday
night raw at uh independent show for
ring of honor at at a
what looked like a [ __ ] hockey rink
in san antonio or something of the like
and at the biggest independent
professional wrestling show ever uh
in chicago in 2018
and
just knowing what it's actually like
behind the scenes
if i ever felt like anything was wrong
or anything didn't
didn't look right
i would speak up and the cool part about
heels is that
mike o'malley
pete siegel who's an ep but directed six
of the eight episodes or jessica lowry
who directed three and four
if anyone was ever not sure about
anything
i would be consulted
and it was you like that i love it i
love it i felt
like
for reasons that
i i think are obvious because of the
place that i was in my career when i
when i accepted this job
i am much more of a partner on heels
than i
ever was on arrow
how so just because of more of the
consulting well think about think about
when you were hired as as lex on
smallville
right
do you remember
approximately what you made
in your first year doing the show
money yeah money we don't need to talk
about this specific figure but yeah i'm
sure you remember
yeah i remember would you have done it
for free
for free yeah like if if you knew
if you could go back and you could look
at what smallville was and what it's
done what it what it what it's done and
what it did for you
like when i when i got when i got aero i
know what i got paid in that first year
but i also know
that if warner brothers would was like
we want
eight hundred dollars
paid to us per episode and then we'll
start paying you next year
okay
right so you go on to that show
as
someone that they hired i came on to
heels as a partner
it's not a criticism it's not a
criticism of the priorities no it's just
a different but it's just a different
thing right they offered it to me
this show got green lit because i said
yes
so you just walk in with a different
relationship
that makes a lot of sense
you're an ep
i'm not you're not
i'm not an ep i would i would
i would like to be
um we haven't formally had those
conversations that this is not a passive
comment i would like to be an ep because
i feel like i actually bring
i would like to be an ep because i
actually feel like i would bring value
as as an ep you wouldn't be just an
actor with an ep credit no no you do the
hands on you know i mean
and and listen like
i i know i know what i could do as an ap
i don't know what i mean we have two
wonderful eps in our show julie yorn and
patrick walmsley and the reason that i
know that they're good is because
everything runs smoothly and i have no
[ __ ] idea what they do
so i said to patrick i said like
what do you do like i don't know i'm
serious
and and i mean this is like the hot this
is the highest form of compliment
because
you probably put out fires on a daily
basis and he goes i do i go i've never
heard about one of them producer that's
what i do
okay that's a good producer you don't
want to know about the problems if
you're hearing about all the [ __ ] that's
going on you can't focus you can't do
the best you can did you when preparing
for this did you have any input in terms
of like i want this to kind of have the
grit of like a wrestler the movie the
wrestler with jackie rourke mixed in
with you know
something else but you want did did you
talk a lot about what it's going to look
like how it's going to feel because
there is that grittiness and that
darkness and that it's not just a light
show
of uh this little town where you know
they're doing independent wrestling
there's some [ __ ] that goes on and that
you know the fact that you know your
brother is kind of a fuck-up but he's
supposed to play this nice guy he's uh
you know that you're wrestling in the
small town i mean
did you have a lot of input into like
you're like i want to know what this is
going to look like what's your vision
the nicest thing that i can say about
the pilot and my manager michael garnett
said as well and she said when he after
he saw the first episode he goes that is
exactly how i [ __ ] pictured it when i
read it
that's great it really was yeah and
the thing that i'm most proud of because
because i did have an idea for it but
you got to remember that
this is independent professional
wrestling so what does the duffy dome
look like it doesn't look like sofi
stadium okay
it's a [ __ ] piece of [ __ ] barn right
that has character and it looks great
when it's filled
but it probably smells like piss right
and stale beer
and these guys are coming out
and sure the costume designer laura
bauer chris bauer's wife who's
who i'm very very excited for her emmy
win this september it's going to be
a year september from now just keep the
receipts please on that one just time
mark thank you
um
you got to create these awesome
you know wrestling like wrestling gear
but it can't look too fancy because
these guys can't afford it right right i
like the get up i would not be seen no i
like it too but you know when the macho
man or ric flair is coming out in those
robes
those are like six seconds it would make
sense for this independent wrestling no
of course not or like or like when stars
i have a i have a match in episode three
and and stars had a note
like
hey so when steven's wrestling uh phil
phil brooks uh professional wrestler cm
punk
some of the punches that he's hitting
with don't look like they're actually
landing
and the show writer goes well i mean
it's not great it's not you know
he's doing his best and stuff like that
but it's not real but the fact that
laura bauer and costume design and she
is
i assume i mean not like
you know
game of thrones money but she has money
to put towards his wardrobe that's great
great stuff it's fantastic and the fact
that stars can take a note like yeah no
no no we're not going to explain to the
audience that steven's not actually
hitting phil we're just going to assume
like they were good with it right and
yeah i forget what the actual question
is i'm just no
you answered were you nervous filming in
front of all these people these
wrestling scenes
no man you just were pumped up you're in
the zone [ __ ] pumped up uh pete
siegel his son sean uh who is uh
at uh at usc right now shout out to sean
by the way pete siegel directed one of
our everyone out there's favorite movie
tommy boy he's also directed everything
else and his original and the original
longest yard and no
i know
i know they might have thought you know
no but his uh his son is a
composer and he composed my
theme music ah when your character comes
out i gotta tell you
you don't get nervous because when your
theme music hits
and you're walking out and our extras at
the duffy doll were extraordinary these
were 200 yeah the energy was really good
200 people they all had to enter into a
cobot protocol
and they all had to be moved around the
duffy dome
because we
wanted to put 800 people in there but
couldn't right
and these [ __ ] had to work like
12 14 16 18 hour days and they brought
it they really did like i i mean in in a
weird way i think that
the covet oddly made them feel like a
little bit more a part of the process
because of what they had to sacrifice
and what they had to do yeah
today's episode is brought to you by
bright
sellers if you've ever been overwhelmed
in the wine aisle and bought a random
wine you ended up hating you're not
alone folks finding the perfect wine
match can be intimidating but it doesn't
have to be and that's where bright
sellers comes in bright cellar uses a
wine algorithm to match you with wines
you're guaranteed to love all you have
to do is take their 30 second quiz which
i took and they match you with wines
based on things you know you like like
your favorite type of chocolate or
favorite type of juice look at this
wonderful wine right here this is a vin
blanc as they call it they sent me a
bunch of wine and they
the quiz is so cool because they're like
do you like this or this what option and
you're like oh this like they said in in
here chocolate what type of chocolate
there's certain things that they'll know
your taste buds based on this algorithm
and you put it in and they sent me like
eight bottles of wine and i've had three
not all in one sitting
but
i liked it it for some reason it it does
it fits each person individually it's
pretty cool bright cellars has done
something real special like each wine
also comes with an education card that
includes information on the region the
wine is from tasting notes food pairings
and serving temperatures you can always
switch up the amount of reds whites and
roses if you're a seasonal wine drinker
and you can skip an order whenever you
want
plus being a bright sellers member means
you get access to their premium wine
portfolio before the wines hit the
market look even if you're not a regular
wine drinker this could be the perfect
gift for that special wine lover in your
life and the best part is that if you
don't like the bottle of wine bright
cellars offers a delight guarantee and
will send you a replacement bottle in
your next order how about that you don't
like wine you can get a different bottle
they are confident ryan they're
confident for a limited time inside of
you listeners get 50
off their first six bottle box by going
to brightsellers.com
inside
it's basically six bottles of wine for
the price of three to get fifty percent
off your first box head to
brightsellers.com
that's b r i g h t c e l l a r s dot com
backslash inside
bright sellers helping you discover wine
that you will love inside of you is
brought to you by better help boy this
company has helped so many people it's
helped me it's helped ryan here uh if
you don't know about better help just
listen up if you're dealing with any
kind of depression anxiety work overload
you got a lot on your mind you just need
to get it out um ryan we've talked about
this you're still doing better help
still doing better health still helping
you you seem like in better spirit i'm
not just saying that but you you can
tell better help helps you get better it
really does it really does and i like
these guys they've stuck with me because
i think it's working i think people are
listening and you know i notice a lot of
my patrons you know they'll respond like
hey better betterhelp's really cool
thanks thanks for introducing me to it
and um it's just one of those
sponsors that's it's not even a hard
sell it's like you know it's so easy to
like do you want to feel better about
yourself do you want to
fix things that you don't like about
yourself better help better help is
there if you're feeling depressed or
struggling with uncertainty or having
difficulty sleeping better help offers
experienced therapists who can listen
and they can help and you can start
communicating in 48 hours or less
uh there's a broad range of expertise
available which may not be locally
available in many areas the service is
available for clients worldwide you can
log into your account anytime send a
message to your counselor and you'll get
timely and thoughtful responses plus you
can schedule weekly video or phone
sessions so you won't ever have to sit
in an uncomfortable waiting room as with
traditional therapy better help is
committed to facilitating great
therapeutic matches so they'll make it
easy and free to change counselors if
needed you know if you have did you have
to change a counselor i did but that was
only because he left the service oh he
left the service okay well there you go
i mean that's the thing you meet
somebody a lot of times you're like huh
i'm not comfortable with this person
right it's so easy you just change
they'll help you change immediately and
it and this is common this happens you
might meet the therapist of your of your
life
you know but you will you'll find the
right one uh it's more affordable than
traditional offline counseling and
financial aid is available and that's
for damn sure um so many people have
been using better help they're
recruiting additional counselors in all
50 states don't even take my word for it
just do it take ryan's word for it if
you want because uh
we really believe in this in this place
better help online therapy and here's
all you have to do it's pretty easy
inside you is sponsored by better help
online therapy and our listeners get ten
percent off their first month of online
therapy at betterhelp.com
inside
that's betterhelp.com
get matched with a better help therapist
and get started
and you're doing your own stunts for the
most part yeah
and so is ace what's his name alexander
ludwig alexander ludwig now i noticed he
did this big backflip
off the ropes
is he is was he a stuntman is he an
athlete was he a wrestler like would it
no yeah i'll tell you what he is
he's
i think still in his 20s and 2 inches
taller than me and 25 pounds heavier
than i am so thanks so much to stars and
lionsgate
for [ __ ] casting my younger brother
as this guy
uh he is a fellow canadian grew up in
vancouver
and loved freestyle skiing
and all that's
just all like he knows how to do
backflips and [ __ ] like that and he's
like hey should do a backflip it's it's
arrogant it's uh you know perfunctory
like it doesn't matter that's what he
should do and you just climb up the top
rope and just do it and stick it every
time
were they worried about you guys getting
hurt or because you i know you probably
are just like i want to do this let me
do this let me do this and they're
constantly like [ __ ] is it is this a
meeting question or do you know what
happened the first day that we shot
wrestling no tell me oh my god
so oh boy when the show opens you see me
type in coast to coast and you see me do
a coast to coast
which is
you get up on the ropes on one side you
jump to the other side of the ring
and you kind of like smash it down like
that with your feet right right
and so anyway we did the first take i i
nailed it i didn't i didn't jump as far
as i wanted to and i didn't realize they
were going to cut to another camera that
was going to be behind the guy that it
was kicking so you know depth of field
you can't tell that i came up short but
i watched it back on the monitors and i
was like well
nailed that
you guys are all set up
we're lit let's do it again and the idea
of doing it again was i want to get as
high and jump as far
as i possibly can
and i did
and i wasn't able to
extend my body so instead i landed
basically sitting straight up with my
legs perpendicular to my torso
compression fracture t10 and l1
vertebrae
day one day one day one of wrestling
and the studio's probably livid oh my
gosh they're flipping out they're not
they're not livid but they're like
really
actually
because you hear broken back
and for the first 24 hours
i didn't think that i'd be back to work
for months because every muscle
around
that area stiffens up stiffens up oh
[ __ ]
they took me
just because i i know you appreciate
this with back stuff and neck stuff they
took me to the hospital now once the
muscles released
released
i was i felt fine
and i was back to work in like three
four days not doing stunts until
a little bit later but it's healed i'm
all good i was very very lucky
um
but
oh goodness i forgot i was going to say
about you you got injured and you
thought you're going to be gone for
months and then you come back and then
yeah everything oh okay so i go to the
hospital
and i'm in incredible amounts of pain my
wife is there
and they're like
uh
scale 1 to 10 what we don't know what's
wrong yet i haven't been x-rayed
scale 1-10 how about your pain and i go
hmm because i couldn't get a full breath
i hope it's a nine and a half
nine yeah i go
deaf i go to nine and a half out of ten
i go i'm an extraordinary amount of pain
to the point that it's making me
introspective like
i i'm in i'm in such pain that i am
outside my body right now thinking about
how i believe
god and the doctor goes looks at
cassandra and says
is
what's his pain threshold like and she
goes it's very high he goes okay
morphine
zofran because i was nauseous and valium
pumped
into my arm
and within five minutes cass goes how
are you and i go
is there a chick-fil-a close by
and one of the nurses says
uh yeah
but why i go
i'm ready can you give me a vanilla
milkshake please she came back the next
day because she wasn't allowed to stay
because of all the cover protocols
because i had to spend the night in the
hospital she came back the next day
she's like what does this room smell
like and i'm like
vanilla milkshake and she's like yeah
why is that i'm like cause i've been
sipping this [ __ ] for the past
16 hours
oh my god so so when did you when were
you able to start filming the the scenes
again those scenes where you're
wrestling i heard it around
halloween
i went back to went back to work
uh
again three four days later we filmed
until thanksgiving and then we broke
from thanksgiving until early january
because a lot of people had to be away
from their families for shooting right
uh and then when i got back i went back
to filming wrestling stuff at the end of
january
all right so you had some months off to
really now were you worried about
because you got covered in the interim
right
no i just gotten back from having
coveted so weren't you worried about
losing all this weight and then you're
injured and you can't really work out
did you i mean because you were rich
you're like you you are thick
thick thank you that's actually what i
was going for on on this show you look
like you i mean that's the build i buy
it if you if you put me in a speedo
right now
they would say this is the first
anorexic you can't you can't be you
can't uh have a physique designed for
a a poster where they do a bunch of you
know um uh
after
touch-ups what do they call it with with
the with the with the camera like we we
[ __ ] [ __ ] up that you make the image
look different
in a better
way uh special effects well sure like
when someone touches up something like
instagram yeah i know you're talking
about instagram versus reality right
right if four heels like
if i walked around like with like an
eight pack people would be like no
i would get destroyed i had to beef up
my legs i was like 25 pounds heavier
than i am right now
what about james harrison he played for
the pittsburgh steelers did he ever
right big football player how is it like
working with this guy and how did they
cast this guy nfl football player whose
idea was this first of all james he's
really good he's really charming
well so james you've only seen one
episode he he plays a guy that is uh in
recovery that is that is uh sober and he
opens the sixth of the seventh episode
uh
uh uh giving the the leaders speech at
an aaa meeting
and he [ __ ]
nails it he is so and he had never
really acted no and he threw himself
into it he threw himself into it with
the same i got to say that
professional athletes
i'm now getting into like a good
groove of working with them because the
thing that they bring the thing that
james brings
is he attacks anything like he would
attack training for a football season
like i asked him about his monologue at
the beginning of an episode because it's
long
and he's like bro i've been working on
that [ __ ]
four weeks we good i'm like okay he's in
the gym every morning at 4 30.
his his workouts are
they're legendary ryan you were telling
me yeah he popped up on instagram
because he was playing volleyball with
like a medicine ball yeah
so james all right i'm gonna sell one
james harrison story it's huge
okay all right here we go
i've got 11 but i'm going to tell one
when we all first got there in in august
about a month before we went to camera
so basically a year ago right now
they built us a gymnasium at the heels
gymnasium where james was james was
there every day
six days a week
at between 4 45 and 5 o'clock
he works out for two and a half hours
and then he sticks around and yells at
me as i'm working out
but
um
[Music]
they're trying to schedule when we
should work out there and they're
putting some of us in the afternoon
james like no one works out in the
afternoon
why is that james and this is the bill
hill the production manager
and while upm one of our producers
awesome guy shout out to bill hill
he goes hey bill when you wake up
first thing in the morning did you dick
hard
oh my god and bill goes uh
something else occasionally occasionally
james
goes well
that's when you work out
you work out in the morning before you
eat
when your dick's hard
otherwise
you're just trying to not get fat
and that was it so the no afternoon
workouts for the rest of the season
that's james james is wow that's amazing
james we were listening to a song once
in the gym and he says to me like
steven i once
tailed a guy in pittsburgh listen to
this song
for two and a half hours with my boy
okay he followed his fault he followed a
guy
and
anyway i i i'll tell that story off the
air
this is the [ __ ] funniest story that
i've ever oh man
he's such a uh he's a really wonderful
and uh thoughtful guy
and
it would
be super easy for him
to think that
a role like apocalypse on heels where he
has he has some episodes where he
doesn't have a lot to do
would maybe be beneath him
as like a former nfl defensive player of
the year
he's going in the hall of fame
uh he's going to be the first
i think he's going on the first ballot
which will make him the first
undrafted player
undrafted he was not drafted
to go into the hall of fame on the first
ballot be very easy for him to be like
oh this is above me excuse me beneath me
but he
he wants to do this he's committed and
he's really
really really good
what do you love most about heels what
do you love mostly about this show
because what i liked is the grit also
the scope i love how it was shot i love
the characters and i really liked that
especially in the i only saw one
but the it just was unpredictable at the
end yeah i just was like i was looking
with the fans
in the uh duffy center or whatever duffy
dome duffy dome duffy george i've got my
mouth to gate because that was the to me
i was just like holy [ __ ] what
it was just like this cliffhanger where
you were like it was it was it it amazed
me did you want to watch the second one
yes that's what i'm saying it made me
want to watch the second one you want to
wrap this up early and hold hands and
watch it right now or no
what do i love about it yeah i love the
words
michael waldron
you know just did loki is doing the new
doctor strange movie he's doing star
wars
he grew up in small town georgia a big
wrestling fan
and so he created this world he knows it
he wrote it
in a way that
only he could have written these scripts
and what a dream role for you though i
mean
role and i gotta tell you that the other
thing that i like god damn it do i like
the music
i love the music because there's old
[ __ ] there's new [ __ ] yeah there's a
song that opens and closes episode three
called yamaha by delta spirit you put
one of my songs it's in the bar scene
it's in the background but you still put
one of my songs in there is that true
yeah sun spin song
there's a sun spin song in your ep in
episode uh
too they told me it was in a bar is this
what made me mad and got me thrown off
the plane because i don't remember this
at all really but it is what the [ __ ]
are you doing producer called me or the
guy said hey we're putting one of your
songs in the thing i'm like great you
can't you can barely hear it but it
doesn't matter i was just i still get
paid sure i got paid
oh and i like
i like that first of all that's terrific
yeah but like and i'm thinking i'm
having like flashes of this now but i
like the fact that we have an old
school
opening credits
yeah
yeah what do you mean sorry we have a
smallville style
opening credits with the characters
where you see the characters i love it
it's just fitting small town jeff
who is the ceo of stars and then just an
all-around wonderful guy
and put a lot on the line for the show
because we were the first star show to
go back
during the pandemic and
they i'm sure they had to spend money
[ __ ] hand over fist to make this
thing work with all the with all the
testing and experience to keep everyone
safe and they did
doesn't matter that i got it that other
people got it there was not one
transmitted case
onset the entire year period
actually
um
it it
oh no i lost my what you like about the
show all these things that you like
about the show yeah and and now okay
this we're definitely gonna have to edit
it out because i forgot what i was gonna
go about this it was a little like
just in general like the the opening i
just love the fact that there's just
opening credits yeah i like it too it's
just it's got it's got a great like it's
got a great like theme song
and i and i hope
uh taking it back to the opening of your
podcast
never change it ever don't update it
hey uh
i would totally marry your wife not
cassandra
oh no in the show oh my goodness yeah
she's fine that didn't come out right i
mean she's fantastic and she was
beautiful like oh my gosh
yeah she's pretty pretty woman i am not
your wife i have a good story about her
that you'll appreciate that you can't
talk about no i that i can talk about
if you'd like well let's hear it
i wanted to i did a very selfish thing
i wanted us to
have
this amazing memory
together
to help build chemistry
for us in the show
so i
did a chemistry read with allison luff
who plays my wife and
a few other actors
in la in
jesus murphy
early 2020 or
late early 2020
and we came out of the session and i was
like i got in touch with mike o'malley
our showrunner and i said it's allison
like it's it's allison it please let it
be allison
and he said i agree with you but you
know it aft we have to go through the
process and i said okay well
if she gets approved can i call her and
tell her that she got the job
because i i don't know i've watched
spielberg that's sweet
i watched spielberg tell the kid from
e.t whose name i don't know that like
henry johnson okay thank you
shout out
and uh he
he got in touch with me at like 7 30 at
night
on a saturday
and you're just like it's allison
i said okay can i call her because she
had screen tested like six days earlier
and she's under a holding deal like so
you called her so i called her and she
was in new york and she was out with her
girlfriends
and she didn't pick up until like it
rang for the eighth time and i'm like
hey
she goes i wasn't gonna pick up
how are you and i said i'm i'm good how
are you she goes i'm [ __ ] steven
she goes i've never i've never lived in
georgia she's like i've signed this deal
i don't know what's going on
and if you're asking me i'm with my
girlfriends and i'm frankly i'm a little
stressed and i said well i just called
to say
that uh
i can't wait to work with you you got
the job and go enjoy
and she screamed in my ear like i can't
[ __ ] hear it on my right ear
for a second i thought you were saying
that she already found out that she was
upset that she was moving to
that's fantastic she screamed in your
ear oh she's and it was it was just it
was just the best and i and and i say
that it was a selfish move and
occasionally being selfish i think is
appropriate and and frankly even could
be helpful
that i i wanted us to have that memory
when she walks onto a set i wanted to
think about that phone call
because as you know i i i'm i'm sure
you've gotten that call it's a
transformational
it's a life altering absolutely i did
that with uh an actress as well
yeah um
what sucks is i i said uh you know i'm
gonna call her because i got her to
audition i got her to be get interested
in the part because the guys liked her
and i was in the ep and i
she got the part and i called her and
said hey it's yours and
she was all excited and then for
whatever reason they didn't want to go
back
in the show they didn't want to go back
to the town where i was from they wanted
to stay where i was or ended up so they
didn't need that character anymore
so then i had to call her and tell her
that
we're not going to be using her anymore
so it was kind of brutal because i loved
working with her and it was just like
god i get you know i got to the
you know it wasn't great all right this
is it this is stephen amell [ __ ] talking
questions from my lovely patrons this is
fast this is rapid fire
that's not how i work but i'm gonna do
it for you you gotta do it
uh
claudine anne how did you find uh doing
that uh accent little southern draw
the good thing about doing certain draws
is jack spade is that you make it make
it simpler but if you're gonna have to
say something like you hey hey kiddo sit
over there put your tushy on the floor
how are you gonna say that if you're not
doing a
southern accent matter of fact i'm
legitimately want to live the rest of my
life this way
it makes me feel so good i love it i can
wear jeans i can wear boots
can i do the rest of the podcast this
way or do you think i'm doing it i don't
think he should but i like it oh by the
way i grew up in southern indiana and i
have friends that talk like that and
when i go back home i tend to jump into
and i start talking like that too and
it's very easy for me so from an
affirmation perspective yeah how how to
do i thought it was fantastic you know
what i liked about it i thought that it
was subtle i thought you weren't pushing
it and i thought that it could easily be
pushed because there's an actor on
walking dead who just [ __ ] pushes the
[ __ ] out of it and you're just like oh
well i don't know what you're talking
about michael rose hey man i'll tell you
have a blessed day hey there's another
zombie
uh you vote your vore how is working
with cm punk and is there a chance of
seeing you wrestle in aew
uh second question first yeah i i would
love to pop up an aew uh you know cody
rhodes is my very good buddy mac and
matt nick of young bucks
all that stuff and working with phil
uh
phil brooks aka cm pump punk echoes
everything that i said about james
harrison
phil had a bunch of [ __ ] words to say
he had a bunch of [ __ ] and
he
he was excellent he was playing a
character he's playing that mid carter
on the indie circuit he's playing a
character called ricky rabies
when's this airing by the way
um
i don't know soon soon well in episode
three
just keep in mind regardless people are
going to watch it on stars and they can
binge it yeah get the app you got to get
the app i guess i bought it
i got show time for you i swear on my
mother's life
i got no i i bought show time it was ten
what you mean stars stars why did i say
[ __ ]
i bought stars
you [ __ ] bought show time for the
dexter reboot and you're not gonna
complain about show time for the comedy
store documentary and for the uh ufo but
that's showtime stars i got for you
because i didn't know anything else that
stars had but stars has a lot of [ __ ]
now that i look but i appreciate that
but go ahead everything that that that
james did i mean he he had a lot he had
a lot of words to say he really did and
he threw himself into it and he was so
good
that we brought him back for our season
finale but if this is gonna air after
the third episode just know that his
character ricky rabies
at our match uh flies uh
flies a possum drone
from the entranceway of the duffy dome
to the middle of the ring
and it it levitates right in front of me
and then spits blood all over me before
a match
that's [ __ ] indie wrestling right
there that [ __ ] happens
and it's amazing wow
i love that jesus
uh that's like ozzy osbourne [ __ ] denver
w not really question just wanted to say
thanks for always sharing and opening up
on the podcast
all of you are helping people and doing
a good job at it so
kudos to you because that anxiety stuff
and whenever you open up and you just
tell i mean it does help so well i
actually
just so wha what was that person's name
that was denver denver
if
ever i'm
feeling
bad
or
anxious which doesn't really happen that
much anymore i think about the way that
i was feeling in this room that we're in
right now
like am i anywhere close to that
no well then i'm okay
it's a good way to look at it because
you were i remember this room gets nicer
by the way every time i come in it does
i added some wood wood paneling
do you remember do you remember you i
was sitting here sitting on this side i
was sitting right there
sorry we're stoned yeah okay sorry
i probably would have laughed as opposed
to start to cry but i remember remember
i just started to sweat oh you're like
is it is it hot in here it was december
open up a door or something yeah rosie
was here rosie i don't know
i don't really feel great you were
i was i was a little i was a little
worried and ryan was i had experienced
anxiety so i was like i know you're
going to be okay but ryan was like oh
[ __ ]
yeah i know when you guys did a little
brief interlude between
the
the first time that came the second time
that i came
uh i've done my you singing voice but my
ryan impersonation is
dude he was literally falling apart
right in front of us
yeah
but rightfully we're doing so much all
right listen to this steph a really this
is a question that everybody wants to
know do you have any plans to return
back to the superhero genre have you
been approached can you see yourself
returning to uh a reunion of arrow or
doing something in the superhero world
or have you not been approached by any
of that or would you consider it if you
were um if i had been approached i
wouldn't say
but i have not
i think way away no no i know i know
okay
i know it made sense
you know i was i was thinking about this
question as i as i drove here
and um
if
if the opportunity ever came up to like
do
[Music]
six to eight episodes of arrow as like a
limited series
on netflix or hbo max or
something like that where
or on the cw as the case may be
i think that'd be amazing
so you'd do it if it was a limited
series sort of like straight either
streaming or under 10 episodes that was
doable and you would do something like
that
uh no i actually wouldn't put a limit on
it at all i think the idea of
of
uh coming back and
playing oliver queen at any point in my
life
it is a really fun idea
um the example being
like
you know michael keaton's about to be
[ __ ] batman again yes he is i'm going
to be happier it has been
29 years
since he played batman
it's been like six and a half minutes
since i played
i love
playing oliver queen
and
and just in general the idea of like
going going back to that character as
i'm getting all these new reps
as an actor and feel like i'm getting
feel like i'm getting better
i mean that's it's it's intoxicating but
it
from you know
hand to god i have not been approached
at all
hand to god
uh heels is on stars i suggest you watch
it it's gritty it's dark it's funny
it's got everything you want um you get
to see this guy in a speedo i don't know
why the [ __ ] you wouldn't want to tune
in just for that those are trunks
they're called trunks is that what
they're called yeah they're they're
they're they're they're they're they're
the clothes i should never wear those i
could never
unless somebody really you can't you
could on the show and in fact if you
ever guest star on the show you have to
my legs are so thin it's not about the
legs you're not going to worry about the
legs
you're going to worry you're going to
worry about the fact that people are
going to be able to tell what religion
you are based off of
i'm not so much worried
so what you have to do is
you have to you have to cover you have
to cover it up so it becomes one
one just general area
general package area not like oh that's
where his dick is okay i wrestled in uh
seventh and eighth grade really quick to
play hockey i was
sixteen and one uh uh
eight of the matches i won by fourth
because i was so light in weight that no
one was there to wrestle me
that's the absolute truth but i i wasn't
bad i could still do a cross-face cradle
i uh i was good i'm scrappy
i knew how to do it i could wrestle i
mean
this kind of wrestling is a little
different yeah you know people say you
know they could sit there and say you
know it's fake and all this stuff but
the amount of pain that you go through
that these guys go through
is real the the the falling jumping off
the ropes and the hitting you still are
getting hit okay so you're still getting
has probably seen wrestling and has seen
heels but
doesn't know a ton about professional
wrestling that's probably true is that
true that's very true
what is the ring mat made of
uh heavy canvas
it is
one layer of canvas
over a giant
wooden like
plywood
are you serious yes plywood plywood so
you're falling essentially on wood and
canvas that's correct okay pain and so
the middle of the ring has the most give
to it
and the outsides of the ring like closer
to the turnbuckles have ostensibly no
give
right so
okay
and and to that end
the ropes in the ring
what are they made of
don't tell me like bridge wire or some
[ __ ] they are steel cables with tape
over them
okay so well why do they do that why
don't they make them more comfortable i
don't i don't
right wouldn't that be nicer i do i do
feel like i i do feel like the wrestling
industry is occasionally like
like like the like the rich old man that
refuses to buy a new nice tv right
watching the [ __ ] packers rams game
on standard definition and you're like
come on man he's like
my tv worked that's how the wrestling
that's how that's how the wwe does it so
i mean
the gym that they built us
when we go there uh one side was weights
and one side was a practice ring
and my warm-up every day was just going
and running the ropes
and then taking a flat back bump in the
middle of the ring
which just means
falling backwards
fall down hit the canvas
well
it stinks just to hit the canvas
yeah it does because if you don't tuck
your chin and if you don't displace the
if you're hurting yourself your head's
going to snap back and you're going to
get your bell wrong
and so i so you take the flat back bump
i took like like five or six just up
down up down up down and then i'd run
the ropes and i know that i'm not
actually running the ropes until i get
the full mid thoracic
adjustment
that happens
from
the ropes
from hitting the ropes
it is no [ __ ] joke these guys i
wrestle cm punk in the third episode
like we talked about
he spent more time in the gym
warming up he's two years older than i
am maybe three
spent more time in the gym warming up
than i did working out
just limbering up his body jesus
real deal ryan i don't want any part of
it
me neither i want a stunt man i want a
good stunt man
i want to you know
and a really good close-up
right after i make impact
that's what i'm talking about steven
this is uh awesome you're always welcome
i hope you'll come back next year
because you're you're my you've been on
more than any other guest now is that
you're not more than welling i think
this is your third or fourth oh that's
what i meant this is my four
i think it is fourth and a half but it's
it's worth it it feels like i mean we we
talked about mostly different things
today hey how is tom tom's doing well he
just had another kid all right good so
he's got two kids
you just have the one right just
maverick
yeah she's adorable i see all the
pictures of you guys jumping into a lake
and [ __ ] like that and just she's the
best man what a joy to you i can tell
you so much joy mavi mavi is uh adorable
but she's she's about to be eight in
october she's a handful doesn't she she
is a handful she is she is she is her
mother she she doesn't need
she doesn't need anything
from
[Music]
anyone she is her own person she and and
this has been supercharged by the
pandemic because
she hasn't had to
like she hasn't been really interacting
with people so it's it's about like her
making up her own
day stuff like that and she crushed it
um
with virtual learning
went grade one in uh miss gary's class
and
she's amazing now but it's just like
it's she's her mom she's beautiful and
smart
and thoughtful and
doesn't like to be hugged
it's like her mom just like her mom
doesn't like to be hugged no she doesn't
she doesn't all right before you go you
just put the sunspin hat on for one
second 100 this is my band's hat he
likes the hat he's gonna wear it he
didn't even know it's my band well there
it is look at that it looks good on you
dude look at that look over here i'm i i
will if i can have one of the coasters
i'm kidding take one no i'm like well i
have so many coasters i have so many as
well
does it you're gonna want to set you're
you're gonna be like why didn't i wear
this the whole time
should we
start again no hey so i want to bring up
the
before we start i got asked to get off
the plane
stephen and mel thanks for allowing me
inside of you man it's always a pleasure
thank you michael i loved it i loved all
of it
[Music]
i enjoyed that i loved how he talked
about uh the plane he wanted to just say
hey this is what happened
and he took blame
and he felt shame yeah it was just like
you know it was like a real conversation
a lot of people like i don't want to
talk about this
stephen always brings it he always is up
for talking about things and i
appreciate that don't you yeah
uh yeah because i think that's the thing
that everyone would have wanted to know
about
and he wanted to come and tell you he
wanted to tell me and i i really love
that i love that he did that and um
yeah he's always got something going on
you know whether it's covet or he has an
anxiety attack stephen you always bring
it
i really appreciate so dramatic he is
and it's uh it's great and he he loves
the podcast and i gave him an inside of
you hat
and uh
sunspin hat i gave him as he's
supporting the sunspin band you can get
a sunspin hat at sunspin.com in fact you
can get 10 off right now if you go to
sunspin.com all merch
10 off rob is 10 is the password or code
that's not the word code yeah code
discount discount code and uh go on the
inside you online store if you want lex
stuff smallville stuff there's still
some small lunch boxes funko pops uh
inside you merch uh new tumblers uh lots
of great stuff go to the inside of you
online store get 10 off and the discount
code is ryan is ten
ryan is one zero it's like a big
situation tom hanks yes the sunspin.com
is rob is ten one zero
um i will be in atlanta georgia for
dragon con this coming weekend come see
me then the following weekend in
lexington kentucky at the lexington toy
con or whatever and i'll be doing a
smallville nights we've already sold a
lot of tickets so get your ticket get to
lexington get to atlanta west virginia
i'll be there
um
september 24th i believe that weekend
and uh
lots of cool stuff going on man how are
you feeling ryan you don't feel all
right yeah okay still doing the better
help still doing the better help yeah
that's good man
you got to keep got to keep rolling got
to keep staying on top of your health
man yeah man uh what else have i done
trying to exercise more yeah you look
good you got the haircut i like the
haircut you look suave
yeah yeah i feel lighter on my head
good that's that's really good it's
tasty yeah the lightness on top of my
head is helping the lightness on the
inside of my head maybe that's a thing
yeah seen a good movies lately i saw
this movie blood red sky
um and it was fun it was a little horror
movie with dominic purcell i met him at
a convention and uh i actually enjoyed
the movie i thought it was kind of dark
and
fun it was kind of like a train to busan
on a plane oh i saw the um saw the valve
documentary the valve documentary
brought tears to my eyes man how
vulnerable is val kilmer in that
documentary it was interesting i feel
like there are some stuff that was left
out though you do like why uh probably
from another perspective
really mm-hmm
i couldn't help feeling you know like
other people's uh perspective of how he
was to work with and things like that
yeah i think it kind of brushed over
that a little bit it brushed over it but
uh it's heartbreaking that he hated
playing batman though
yeah i don't think he hated as much as
he hated the costume and he was limited
he couldn't move around and everyone
else got to do the big
big parts yeah yeah um he didn't seem
happy with that but maybe there's a time
in his life i don't know i'm sure he was
difficult as [ __ ] to work with i'm sure
he was very difficult but
also a brilliant actor and sometimes
with brilliance comes
pain in the ass
the twain was pretty incredible actually
yeah it's mark twain yeah it's just
amazing at the end it's just a shame the
whole thing i wonder if they could
reverse his you know he lost his uh he
had the throat cancer so can they
reverse that
you know like that kind of can you
reverse that and i'm not making fun of
it i'm just trying to i don't know it's
heartbreaking though it is it is
heartbreaking uh hey guys thanks for
listening to the podcast
patreon.comcity if you want to give
a little more to the podcast um i'll
message you after it's it's a really
great uh thing you'll you'll really
enjoy it look go to p-a-t-r-e-o-n
patreon.com inside of you there's a lot
of tiers a lot of extra things goodies
and things like that i send boxes to
um
my patrons and with little notes every
couple months and we do a lot of fun
things and you get information before
anybody else does and discounts before
anybody else does so all my love to my
patrons and let's read out the patrons
why don't we do that
here we go nancy d leah s tricia f sarah
v little lisa kiko jill e
uh-huh i gave you that one brian h mama
lauren
oh i forgot the og yes nico p jerry w
robert l jason w apophian kristen k not
kristen
amelia oh alison l raj c joshua emily
cj
did i get that one right emily you did
yes all right cj p samantha uh m yes
jennifer p n and stacy l jan
s jamal
f janelle
b
kimberly e mike he el don
primo 99 more ramira santiago
oh um i can't believe you're getting all
these n's
sarah v sarah f chad
uh
w chadw leanne p janine r
ray
uh a maya p
maddie s shannon d matt
w belinda
and and right kevin
v james r
holy [ __ ] this is the furthest you've
gotten chris
oh chris uh h yes and also dave h yes
spider-man chase sheila g brad
d ray
h i can't believe what we're doing here
tabitha t tom
um
and
liliana
a michelle
k michael
s yes talia
and m i'm mixing all the c
d
claire
v m laura
v l chad
another chad l
rochelle nathan e
marion just listen to these because next
time i'm gonna get you in these marion
med k
janelle p trav l dan n
yes carrie
h
veronica k big stevie
w kendall
jenner t
carol d angel m rhiannon c cory k
super sam emily c coleman g den veksen
michelle a liz l jeremy c andy t cody r
sebastian k gavinator and h david c
elliott m john b brandy d yvore camille
s bono banno the c
the c joey m pt scarborough and willie f
give it up for ryan man
i mean you nailed it i mean that's the
furthest you got you've gotten a lot i
guess i'm doing it phonetically because
i'm mixing all the m's and ends it's
hard i don't know how you do that well
it helps when you have a visual aid
yeah i can't do it i couldn't do this
you do it 77 times in a row yeah i just
don't have that comprehension where i'm
like i don't absorb what i read it takes
me a couple times to read something
before i absorb it do you
yeah no i i reread paragraphs all the
time yeah i think there's some kind of
dyslexia or something with me i'm just
have slow learning curve i you know like
things i have to really it's hard for me
to focus and pay attention and when i do
i can get it or if i'm really interested
then i'm really on top of it
it just depends how much i want to learn
that's true
uh this has been great i love you guys i
appreciate you listening to the show i
hope you enjoyed stephen amell please
follow us all that stuff
please write a review spread the word
especially on my patrons who are
probably the only ones listening at this
point
um continue to spread the word get your
friends get your relatives get everybody
to you know ask them please
and um
subscribe to the podcast because it
really helps and uh we love you from
hollywood hills in california i'm
michael rosenbaum i'm ryan tez uh wave
at that camera up there ryan
we love you guys thank you for allowing
me to be inside of each and every one of
you each week come back and see us ryan
he'll be sitting right there
all right thank you
[Music]